thank you very much everybody we had
just finished a signing very important
signing of the tax payer first bill the
IRS tax payer first which is a
tremendous thing for our citizens having
to do with the IRS streamlines and so
many other changes made so that was just
done and signed and it's been made into
law so we're all set on that and today
I'm signing a bill to deliver a four
point six billion dollars in
humanitarian assistance to our southern
border this includes funding for medical
care shelters and increased housing for
minors through the Department of Health
and Human Services and the secretary is
here with us and with our vice-president
and with some of our congressmen we
appreciate thank you very much for many
weeks Democrats were giving us a hard
time but I tell you it became a
bipartisan bill we were very happy about
it and now what we want to do is we have
to do a bill for border security and all
of this will go away I want to thank
Mexico because Mexico is doing a lot
right now they have almost 20,000
soldiers between the two borders there
6,000 on their southern border by
Guatemala and they have about 16,000 15
16,000 at our southern border and the
numbers are way down for the last week
because this just took place over the
last few days over the last week and
it's way down as you can imagine but we
have to do a bill on border security and
we can solve the problem entirely at our
border the wall is being built but
unfortunately we had a very bad case
from the Ninth Circuit as usual a Ninth
Circuit Judge and I say that loud and
clear very hard to win at the Ninth
Circuit if not impossible he ruled
against something that in my opinion was
a terrible error and it really affected
the construction of part of our wall
much of it's being built most of it's
being built but it had a an impact these
were contracts that were out they were
being built and that was supposed to
stop because the judge decided in his
own
whim that he wanted to stop it so we
appealed it and we're asking for an
expedited appeal but again much of the
wall is being built we had it all being
built and the Ninth Circuit as usual
came through for the other side and it's
an incredible situation we have knowing
is something wrong with this where
something like this can happen it's not
a good situation
anyway we're asking Congress to step
forward on border security and help us
with border security we do that it's
going to be perfect because the Mexicans
have done a fantastic job and I want to
thank the President of Mexico and
they've done this over the last week and
a half it started at the other border
and now it's at our border and it's had
a very big impact you'll see the numbers
come out you probably have to wait three
or four weeks but we'll see there's a
tremendous difference and most
importantly we must eliminate all
incentives for smuggling children and
for smuggling women their smuggling
women through borders and the borders
that don't have the wall or the borders
where you can't physically have security
because it's so many miles you know we
have 2,000 miles of border so they're
smuggling in women and they're smuggling
in children and they're using the
children in particular as pawns we're
getting other people into our country
because when you're with the child even
if the child's not yours which in itself
is ridiculous that it's much easy to
come across and come into our country
because the laws are very bad our
immigration laws are very bad and right
now smugglers coach migrants to travel
with minors and to send minors alone to
gain easy entry into the United States
catch and release my stop DHS must have
the authority to humanely return minors
to be with their families in their home
countries it's right now a situation
where nobody knows what they're doing
because our laws are so bad and it can
be changed and I always say 15 minutes
make it an hour it's very simple these
changes are very simple as changes to
the asylum
if we change the siloam we can have 75
percent of it done the rest has to be
done on the loophole
vast migrations out of Central America
undermined the future of those countries
and these countries now they want their
children back they're actually wanting
their children back as you know I
stopped hundreds of millions of dollars
from going to Guatemala Honduras and El
Salvador because they haven't been doing
what they should be doing caverns have
been forming but now the caravans are
being stopped by Mexico and again we
want to thank Mexico but the caravans
that formed are being stopped by Mexico
short of our southern border and in many
cases before they even get out of
Guatemala but I'm hearing that Guatemala
is starting to help us a lot but we're
not paying them all of the money we used
to pay them over 500 million dollars a
year I stopped that money from going to
them some people think it should be the
opposite we should give them money I
don't think they were doing what they
could do and therefore I stopped it and
at some point maybe if they do a great
job in the job they're supposed to we
can be talking but right now it's
disgraceful what's happening and
Congress and the Democrats have to step
forward to provide humane solutions to
put child smugglers out of business you
have child smugglers by the hundreds and
actually probably by the thousands and
they're becoming very rich because our
laws are so bad and have to restore the
integrity of the United States Asylum
system without these changes more than 1
million immigrants will arrive and the
borders this year many of them lodging
frivolous asylum claims and that's what
they do to gain access into the country
they large claims on asylum and they're
totally bogus claims we apprehend these
people but because of catch-and-release
we have to apprehend them
take their names sometimes bring them to
court sometimes they're criminals
oftentimes they have to be released but
they're all coming out of the country
because that's what we do after July 4th
a lot of people are going to be brought
back out so people that come up may be
here for a short while but they're going
to be going they're going back to their
countries they go back home ice is going
to be apprehending
and bringing them back and we have a
very big system for that and it's been
very effective and it will be very
effective so they may feel and you may
read that they came across and because
of the ridiculous laws of
catch-and-release
which I called not a law I call it a
loophole you release them but they go
back they get caught they come in
illegally and they go out illegally very
simple system most border crossers never
show up in court they never come about
three percent show up nobody even knows
why they show up but only three percent
show up but we are apprehending them and
we bring them out of the country in some
cases they're criminals and ideally we
want them to use the other country's
criminal justice system because we don't
want to load up our prisoners any
prisons any more than they're already
loaded up so that's it in a nutshell
it's 4.6 billion dollars it was
bipartisan it was done in a bipartisan
manner we all got together this is a
humane solution to a tremendous problem
that's caused because we have bad
immigration laws that we can solve that
problem very very quickly if we could
get together with the Democrats the
problem is the Democrats actually like
this system because it's open borders
now we don't allow it to be open borders
because we're apprehending and we're
doing a great job Border Patrol has been
incredible
law enforcement has been incredible and
ice has been incredible but it shouldn't
be this way it shouldn't be this way
we're the only ones in the world that
have a system like this it's absolutely
insane our system of immigration and the
reason they come up is because their
economy is doing so well I just got back
as you know from Japan and from South
Korea met with many of the countries of
g20 so yet that the biggest countries
and it was incredible everybody greeted
with me with congratulations on how well
we're doing with our economy we have the
number one economy in the world and a
lot of that is tax cuts a lot of it is
regulation cuts and thank you Kevin and
the group I will tell you it's Patrick
thank you very much and Mike thank you
very much and everybody because of the
tax cuts our economy is the hottest in
the world if we didn't have them we were
paying companies were paying the highest
tax rates in the world just about in
many cases the highest and now we have
them at the low level not the lowest but
we have them at the low level at 21% and
because of that they're coming in new
companies are being formed but we have
many many companies that left our
country and they're now coming back
especially the automobile business we
have auto plans being built all over the
country we went decades and no plant was
built no plant was even expanded and in
leaving Japan I was with Prime Minister
Abbey and he was telling me they have
many more companies now that are moving
to the United States and building plants
in Michigan and Ohio and North Carolina
and South Carolina Florida different
states all over the country and it's
pretty amazing because we didn't have
any of we had no expansions and now we
have a lot of expansion so we are
signing this now and it's an honor to
sign it and if we could do border
security along with it or follow it up
shortly everybody would be extremely
happy I want to thank secretary azar who
is doing an incredible job considering
that the decks are really stacked
against him the cards are are not good
and yet the job you people are doing is
incredible you know we're not in the
hospital business were in the border
security business at the border and all
of a sudden were forced to be in the
hospital business and again they're
coming up because they want a piece of
what's happening in this country they
want the economy they want the jobs
they're not coming up for the most part
for other reasons they're coming up
because they want the jobs and we want
them but we want them to come in legally
through a process and we want them to
come and based on merit
so the merit is very important
and there you have your bill thank you
very much everybody no no message to
Iran they know what they're doing they
know what they're playing with and I
think it playing with fire so no message
to Iran whatsoever in Hong Kong I hope
it gets solved I was with President Xi
of China we had a great talk great
discussion we're talking about doing
something and we talked about it briefly
but that's very sad I rarely see the
protest like that is very sad to see
we're looking at that we think that a
census obviously if you do all of this
work and you're talking about nobody can
believe this but they spend billions of
dollars on the census and you're not
allowed to ask you don't knock on doors
of houses check houses you go through
all this detail and you're not allowed
to ask whether or not somebody is a
citizen so you can ask other things but
you can ask whether or not somebody's a
citizen so we are trying to do that
we're looking at that verse from it's
very important to find out if somebody's
a citizen as opposed to an illegal I
think there's a big difference to me
between being a citizen of the United
States and being an illegal and you know
the Democrats want to treat the illegals
with health care and with other things
better than they treat the citizens of
our country if you look at a coal miner
that has black lung disease you took it
about people that get treated better
than the coal miner and these people got
sick working for the United States and
we treated people that just walked in
better you look at what they're doing in
California how they're treating people
they don't treat their people as well as
they treat illegal
immigrants so at what point is it stuff
it's crazy
what they're doing it's crazy and it's
mean and it's very unfair to our
citizens and we're gonna stop it but we
may need an election to stop it we may
need to get back to the house already
they're speaking very much on phone but
they're also meeting
yeah it's essentially already begun it
actually began before our meeting look
if we don't make a great deal if we
don't make a fair deal it has to be
better for us and for them because they
had such a big advantage for so many
years in other words you can't make a
50/50 deal when somebody else has been
absolutely I've been talking about this
for years China made we had a surplus
meaning they did on us a five hundred
and seven billion dollars it's been
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
for many many years
so obviously we can't make a 50/50 deal
it has to be a deal that is somewhat
tilted to our advantage and if we're not
going to do that would take it in a
fortune from tariffs and unfortunately
we're hurting China by doing that
because many of their companies are
leaving and going to a non-tariff State
so they don't have to pay the tariffs
and the other misconception about China
and I think you read an article today in
the Wall Street Journal about it our
people aren't paying for those tariffs
in that case certainly China is paying
for them and those companies are paying
for them China devalued their currency
very substantially and they also put a
lot of money into their economy they're
pouring money it's fake money but it's
money and they're pouring money into the
economy to take care of the tariff so
people aren't you don't have increased
inflation you have no increased
inflation but I'll tell you what is
happening our Treasury is taken in
billions and billions of dollars of
money that normally would be for China
so we'll see what happens we hope that
we can make a deal but it's got to be a
fair deal we had a deal as far as I was
concerned and then at the last moment
China decided they didn't like that deal
and they changed it so right then I said
you're gonna pay 25 percent tariffs on
two hundred and fifty billion
she said he would move on some of those
issues that weren't affect him to move
and if he doesn't move that's okay too
I'm very happy either way but I think we
have a good chance of making a deal I
think they want to make a deal because
they're losing many companies that are
leaving because of the tariffs because
they don't want to pay the tariffs so
they're losing many companies they're
moving to Vietnam and by the way some
are moving back to the United States
where they belong because I think the
president's doing a great job
you put 16,000 people in this weekend
and they're forming but they're you know
getting to the border and they're doing
a great job and he has six thousand
people at the border with Guatemala so I
mean it's been way down it's cut way
down you'll start to see the numbers
over the next no that's true yeah if
they don't do it but they're doing a
good job right now they're doing a very
good job we're very happy with the job
they're doing no it was because of
tariffs that they're doing it but what
the point is they're doing a very good
job and he's very smart to do it because
that's a tiny fraction it sounds like a
lot of soldiers but that's a fraction of
what tariffs would cost Mexico but I
very much appreciate it and he's doing a
great job for Mexico because the Mexican
people were very upset with all of these
tens of thousands of people hundreds of
thousands of people walking through
Mexico and the people of Mexico are just
as happy as I am with what they're doing
well I don't know what they're saying
about members of Congress I know that
the Border Patrol is not happy with the
Democrats in Congress I will say the
Republicans do one border security the
Democrats want open borders open borders
means tremendous crime if you look there
was a report that came out where
approximately 600 people in the last
Caravan were serious criminals I don't
want them in our country so the border
patrol of their patriots they're great
people they love our country they know
what's coming in and you know who knows
it better than anybody Hispanics
Hispanics love what I'm doing because
number one they don't want to lose their
job they don't want to take a pay cut
and very importantly most importantly
they don't want to have crime they
understand it the people that understand
the border the best are Hispanics they
understand it better than anybody and
they don't want to have to suffer crime
and they don't want to take a pay cut
they don't want to lose their job that's
why my poll numbers went way up with
Hispanics because they really understand
the board of the best of anybody okay
[Music]
we're gonna have a great 4th of July in
Washington DC it'll be like no other
it'll be special and I hope a lot of
people come and it's going to be about
this country and it's a suit to America
and I'm gonna be here and I'm gonna say
a few words and we're gonna have planes
going overhead the best fighter jets in
the world and other planes too and we're
gonna have some tanks stationed outside
got to be pretty careful with the tanks
because the roads have a tendency not to
like to carry heavy tanks so we have to
put them in certain areas but we have
the brand new Sherman tanks so we have
the brand new April tanks and we have
some incredible equipment military
equipment on display brand new and we're
very proud of it you know we're making a
lot of new tanks right now we're
building a lot of new tanks in Lima Ohio
a great tank factory that people wanted
to close down until I got elected and I
stopped it from being closed down and
now it's a very productive facility and
they do
nobody it's the greatest tank in the
world I think so I think so I think I've
reached most Americans most Americans
want no crime most Americans want a
strong military they want good education
they want good health care if you look
at pre-existing conditions the
Republicans are going to say
pre-existing conditions that Democrats
won't be able to do it what the
Democrats plan is is going to destroy
the country and it's going to be
horrible health care horrible health
care and everybody's taxes are going to
go to 95% and by the way that's not
enough but the taxes if they ever did
what they want to do your taxes go to 95
percent and that isn't nearly enough
thank you very much well they're looking
for democracy and I think most people
want democracy unfortunately some
governments don't want democracy but
that's what it's all about it's all
about democracy there's never been
anything better and I think we're the
best example of it right here in the
United States thank you